Welcome to the Sequencer Introduction
for Game Development.
In this class, we'll briefly discuss game development
and how it relates to using Sequencer for game development.
We'll run through core concepts of Sequencer
and the features and tools available through Sequencer.
We'll build an in-game cut scene sequence from scratch.
And finally, run through a few recommendations
on organizing your workflow and layouts
when using Sequencer.
All of the files that you'll need for today's class
are going to be located in your content, courses,
SEQ10500.
And in the Maps folder, you'll find the map
that we're using for today's class.
So let's get started.